chaque fois que je vais regarder sur un
plateau télé votre petite touche
personnelle dû courir complètement
dessus est ce que depuis que vous avez
totalement arrêtée ou pas ça n'est pas
encore ça me prend
[Musique]
et donc à une fille une femme qui s'est
fait connaître dans l'émission famille
nombreuse de la vie en xxl c'est
amandine pélissard regardez à la 8
enfants et regardant l'émission c'est
camille la table tu sais pas ce qu'a dit
ce n'est pas moi qui me lot
[Musique]
c'est un bonheur non on peut pas se
lasser de donner la liste
des coutumes et des trucs qu'on voit des
hongrois toi alex son bébé
alors massa a passé
12 saisons
du temps chez autodesk élections
allaient l'infini tape là aucune
herman düne pélissard depuis cinq
saisons dans l'émission nous a rejoints
il n'y a pas très longtemps vous avez
reçu quatre jusqu'à quatre lettres de
menaces de mort c'est ça et on va dire
peut-être la première parce que c'est
elle concerne vos enfants dont c'est la
plus violente espèce de saloperies avec
ta gueule botoxée tu ressens vraiment ce
que tu es une arabe avec tes cheveux
frisés girondine à ce que je lis un râle
à l'usiné on craint les familles
nombreuses sont les eaux donc c'est
votre fils aîné et sa gueule d'arabe
vraiment j'ai honte de ce que je lis
avec sa choucroute sur la tête alex
complètement conne l'ena petite [ __ ]
malpolis insolente vous comprenez
maintenant pourquoi en allemand la
saison en forme de palmier ça c'est
qu'une dette sur les quatre on n'ira pas
sur les 4 ou est-ce que ce qui a énervé
aussi c'est peut-être pas le fait que
avant de faire cette émission vous
n'aviez pas beaucoup de revenus en
exposant ses enfants dans cette émission
maintenant paraît-il que vous avez des
gros revenus avec grâce aux réseaux
sociaux jusqu'à trente quarante mille
euros par mois et ce qui agace les gens
c'est que vous avez finalement
l'évolution si vous avez instrumentalisé
vos enfants pour un de google et de
l'argent alors vous ne gagnez pas
réalisé mais ensemble des chats c'est la
question que je prenne ce qui se passe à
kathak les gens quelqu'un déjà encore
une fois nous on est là que tu la saison
1 oui c'était mission nous l'a proposé
elle est d elle existait pas imposé qu
avant j'étais vendeuse donc vous gagnez
pas quarante mille euros avant un long
week-end packard bell or aujourd'hui non
clair ah bon c'est ce que j'ai entendu
vouliez-vous faire et par mois ne
convient trois mois par mois bailly 6400
euros par mois bah je te dire merde
mais après on s'en fout peu importe
c'est pas méchant ce que j'ai c'était
pour effet de comprendre tout média qui
n'est pas amendé après mais avant vous
étiez à bord et oui compte épargne à
remplir pour leur majorité donc peu
importe combien je gagne aux médias que
c'est pas une bombe de gagner de
l'argent il n'y a pas de problème mais
je dirai pas combien non mais en tout
cas plus que quand vous étiez vendeuse
oui et dans cinq six ans est tout à fait
l'âge de mon fils adam dont j'avais
parlé on me dit mais lui on le voit pas
et les deux côtés machin non en fait
c'est que nos enfants dont les âges agen
on les a jamais obligé à tourner quoi
que ce soit c'est maintenant en 2022 à
cause des réseaux sociaux qu'on a quatre
cinq agresseurs parce qu'en réalité il
ya des millions de personnes qui
regardent et qui vous adore donc on est
en train de monter en épingle 3 connard
raciste qui a je sais qu'à un moment
vous avez vous aviez dit on attend qu'il
se passe quoi on va attendre que mon
fils se prennent un coup de couteau au
coin de la rue en allant prendre le bus
est ce que vous attendez qu'un drame
pareil abonnés qui n'arrivera pas arrive
pour arrêter les réseaux sociaux ou pour
arrêter d'exciter un peu later tenant
moi ce que j'attends alors j'ai utilisé
cette phrase forte justement voilà parce
que ce qui me dérange beaucoup c'est que
j'en suis à ma deuxième plainte j'ai
déposé plainte deux fois j'ai
l'impression qu'il se passe pas grand
chose et en fait la police pour les
choses un peu de façon légère quand j'ai
déposé ma première plainte que le
policier me dit pouvait prendre un garde
du corps enfin on sent quand même qu'à
une légèreté et vous avez pensé ça avec
l'argent que vous gagnez maintenant
apprendre à me donner des services écrit
non pas 100 je veux pas l'ombre parce
que je veux pas je ne veux pas partir
dans une paranoïa non je suis
normalement
[Musique]
elisabeth sosie officiel de pamela
anderson au delà des shows et de cette
ressemblance avec lamela anderson elle
avait un autre objectif devenir
chanteuse
alors vous avez fait part dont vous avez
été également à rétrécissement vaginale
pour le magma vrai dire oui enfin si
j'avais fait trop de piercings j'avais
quelques piercing g comment vous saviez
que seulement vous saviez pardon que
pamela bien plus petit que le vôtre
une vidéo qu'elle avait qu'elle avait
sorti avec apam avec toi oui ces fameux
donné d'accord
vous que vous regardez la sextape de
pamela taux minimaux détient petite mère
d un centimètre de 30 ans je vivais à
chaque fois que je vais regarder sera
plateaux télé votre petite touche
personnelle et courir complètement
dessus est ce que depuis que vous avez
totalement arrêtée ou pas pas ça dépend
ça dépendra sabran
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
on m'a dit
non mais non mais non rien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci maman
[Applaudissements]
alors qu'il a dit une phrase qui m'a
fait rire beaucoup boire son sperme
quatre fois par jour
c'est le médecin qui a conseillé à kim
kardashian de boire du sport comme tout
va bien mais ça vaut pour un cours un
écart n'est pas fini mais voilà voilà
voilà
[Rires]
du coup de masse que du coup tout cas
on passe à autre chose ou non mais je
peux vous dire quand même que kim elle a
dit aujourd'hui je crois que c'est ce
matin qu'elle était capable de manger
ses propres son propre cas six ans les
jeunes jusqu'à et on était tous d'accord
pour dire que pas pardon j'ai bien sûr
être chaud mais kim kardashian elle et
on laisse aller et comment autant de
gens peuvent s'intéresser à moi je
savais pas qui c'est vraiment pour le
coup là je ne me faites pas ça chez vous
merci
à mes jambes et les femmes qui sont
prêtes à boire le nom
mais vous rendez compte que vous états
unis ça se passe comme ça se fait plus
on n'est pas encore dans sur les
américains soirée spéciale alors on fera
pas le sondage mais c'était une bonne
idée est organisé
et sané dernier d'aucune prestation a
beaucoup ému les téléspectateurs c'est
de morgane une adolescente de 16 ans qui
a choisi de réinterpréter corps 10
heures pour évoquer son surpoids et ce
qui est aussi en surpoids regardez
ça cesse les angevins
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ces auditions à la vue pour moi c'est
une opportunité de prouver que je
m'assume avec mes formes et mes rondeurs
j'ai envie que les coaches se
ressemblent comment j'ai pu souffrir et
comment je me suis relevé qu'ils
ressentent mes émotions bien la réaction
d'amel bent qui elle même aussi on avait
parlé avait souffert un peu de son poids
à l'époque regardez tu as choisi cette
chanson parce que je me suis longtemps
considéré comme un corps et non comme
une dune pillés et du coup j'avais envie
de défendre cette cause
c'est vrai que j'aime énormément cette
chanson parce que j'ai vécu un peu la
même histoire que toi on dirait pas
comme ça mais il ya quelques années
j'étais aussi ré malheureuse par rapport
à mon physique on vit dans une société
qui est ultra grosso faible et on a beau
être dans une dynamique de body positive
il faut les porter les kilos ça reste
quand même un combat tous les jours
c'est vrai je voulais te dire à quel
point je te trouve fortes merci à quel
point tu dois être courageuse plus que
tellement d'autres jeunes femmes de ton
âge père se voit là et merci
quand j'étais assistant sur une émission
de télévision il assisterait pas parce
que j'en ai honte
amel bent venait de faire nouvelle star
et chantaient et elle avait un orage peu
en surpoids et le réalisateur que je
citerai pas non plus et la filmer et il
avait dit au cadreur ne la prenait
jamais par derrière elle a un gros cul
j'étais à côté de ça je l'avais entendu